the US military said this morning that
joint exercises with South Korean forces
at the end of August will go on as
planned North Korea claims they are
rehearsals for war a newspaper in Guam
blared the headline 14 minutes that's
how long it would take for North Korean
missiles to reach the island president
Trump is again asking China's president
to step in Ben Tracy is in Beijing with
new reaction from the Chinese government
Ben good morning good morning China's
government told us today that they have
been working very hard on the North
Korean issue and paid a price for doing
so that seems to be a reference to China
going along with those tough UN
sanctions that will curtail its trade
with North Korea a president Trump says
he wants China to do what he simply
calls more I think China gives you a lot
more yes China can and I think China
will do a lot more president Trump is
simultaneously fueling the escalating
conflict with North Korea and counting
on China to solve it he's threatened a
trade war if they don't but if China
helps us I feel a lot differently for
trade a lot differently portrait if the
u.s. is trying to convince China to take
significant action on North Korea it is
using more stick than carrot on Thursday
the US Navy sailed a destroyer through
contested waters in the South China Sea
just 12 miles off the shore of one of
the islands China claims as its
territory in a terse statement China's
foreign ministry said this severely
harmed China's sovereignty and security
and that China is very displeased
and the Chinese government made another
statement just a few hours ago saying
that both the US and North Korea should
act with caution and stop taking turns
in what China calls shows of strength
Jeff Van Tracy in Beijing then thank you
very much